und auch in dieser Woche bestätigt
unsere Hauptstadt wieder mal jedes
einzelne Klischee gestern plötzlich
Hochspannung und drei Wahlgänge auf dem
Weg zum neuen Regierenden Bürgermeister
was beweist für vollchaos ist Berlin gar
nicht auf Klima Kleber angewiesen und
die kleben da ja auch noch seit Montag
versuchen angeblich hunderte Aktivisten
der letzten Generation möglichst viel
lahm zu legen sind zwischen glaube ich
allseits bekannt das Prozedere aber
natürlich immer noch effektiv nein wenn
die da auf der Straße sitzen was willst
du machen als Autofahrer gut außer
natürlich einfach
drumrum fahren um die Blockade und ich
finde da hätten sie darauf kommen können
dass das die Stelle nicht optimal ist
sage ich mal ne oh Gott ja als nächstes
kleben sich wahrscheinlich in der Mitte
eines Kreisverkehrs fest
so ich weiß nicht wie es Ihnen geht aber
ich finde mittlerweile ist es wie ein
Theaterstück das immer wieder neue
aufgeführt wird immer das gleiche die
kleben sich an dann kommen Autofahrer
und sagen geht arbeiten irgendwer
schubst dann kommt die Polizei mit ihrem
Speiseöl man hat irgendwie über oder ich
finde man hat irgendwie über wie wäre es
denn mal weiß ich nicht mit was Neues im
klebebereich
heute reichen die normalen Lösungsmittel
teilweise nicht mehr aus die Polizei
rückt mit riesentrennschleifern an um
die klimaaktivisten vom Asphalt zu
schneiden jo selber schuld selber Schuld
ab jetzt hat der Johannes hier eine
Asphalt Hand ne das ist ja das ist nicht
optimal ist ihm dann später auch klar
geworden beim Klavierunterricht
ja nur beim Tischtennis war es
eigentlich ganz praktisch
inzwischen hat die letzte Generation
wirklich gar keine Freunde mehr gar
keine sogar die Grünen gehen auf Distanz
während sich bei Autofahrern die
Stimmung muss man sagen weiter Aufheizen
bis hin zur ja Selbstjustiz unschöne
Bilder Justizminister Buschmann waren
schon vor ich zitiere Straßen Schlachten
wie in den 20er und 30er Jahren genau
als Nazis und Kommunisten sich
umgebracht haben umbringen ankleben
merken sie selber ne ja seit dieser
Woche sind die klimakleber wirklich
sowas ja sowas wie das heimliche
Wahrzeichen der Stadt die Idee
vielleicht sollte man Berlin sogar
umbenennen in Themenpark klimakleber
sponsert bei Pattex das wird voll die
Touristenattraktion Japaner können Fotos
mit den angeklebten machen jeden Tag um
14 Uhr ist die große evil knievels dann
schon ne das Springen wütende
Motorradfahrer aus dem Stau mit einer
Rampe über die Aktivisten und natürlich
Kinder schminken also Kinder dürfen den
lustige Kindergesichter malen ja
natürlich ins Stadtbild integrieren
anders wird es nicht gehen absurd wird
für mich wenn es jetzt heißt die
Akzeptanz für Klimaschutz schwindet
wegen der letzten Generation ja genau
wirklich genau alles lief super alle
waren bereit richtig viel zu ändern fürs
Klima aber jetzt wo diese bösen Kinder
durchdrehen mache ich nicht mehr mit ja
die sind wirklich die perfekte Ausrede
für alle die schon länger finden das
Klimaschutz an sich nervt
andere sind wenigstens ehrlich für ihre
Aktion ernten die klimaaktivisten viel
Kritik bei Passanten und Autofahrern
aber auch zustimmen weil er machen muss
und weil ich so faul bin ganz deutlich
Bravo der Mann ist ab sofort mein
persönliches Idol sehr gut ja leider zu
faul wäre tatsächlich auch ein gutes
Motto fürs Berliner Stadtwappen oder
insgesamt diese Woche wurde in Berlin
eine Aktivistin zu vier Monaten ohne
Bewährung verurteilt die was nicht aber
ja es ist vier Monate ohne Bewährung
finde ich ziemlich hart wo ja echte
Gewalttäter in Deutschland oft mit
Bewährungsstrafen davon kommen
gleichzeitig gehört auch zu Wahrheit
macht es einem diese letzte Generation
aber auch ja echt schwer sie zu
verteidigen Stichwort Behinderung von
Rettungswagen und warum klingen die
immer so wahnsinnig missionarisch mir
ein Interviews so latent ja sektenhaft
zutiefst bewegt vom eigenen Martyrium
was würden Sie tun wenn Sie davon wissen
und noch ein Zeitfenster haben diese
Katastrophe abzuwenden was würden Sie
tun als junge Frau dann sperrt uns ein
dann sperrt mich ein aber für jeden
Menschen der in einer Zelle sitzt werden
fünf Menschen sich dem Widerstand
anschließen aber solange das nicht
passiert was soll ich tun als junge Frau
also da ist Philipp Amthor wirklich der
falsche Ansprechpartner
[Musik]
ich wette der kennt mich meine junge
Frau nur eine Theorie Widerstand hat mir
gehört Widerstand denkt sie wäre eine
resistance oder was wirklich wenn ich
diesen ganzen Carlas zuhören bei den
heißen ja komischerweise alle Carla
denke ich oft weniger Pathos wäre echt
besser aber wahrscheinlich können die
inzwischen gar nicht mehr anders auch
privat
ich muss jetzt ins Büro kannst du bitte
die
spülen ja denn wir fahren mit Vollgas
auf dem Heimweg Richtung
küchenkatastrophe hier sieht es aus wie
Sau ist das denn allen egal wir müssen
jetzt die Maschine einräumen ansonsten
ist diese Küche irgendwann unbewohnbar
für uns unsere Kinder und deren Kinder
wir sind die letzte Generation die noch
aus einer sauberen Tasse trinken
Kaffee Kaffee
dauerapokalypse stumpft irgendwann ab
ganz normal also in der Sache gibt ihnen
sogar der Expertenrat der
Bundesregierung Recht der warnt hat
neulich gewarnt dass wir unsere
Klimaziele bis 2030 reißen und zwar mit
Karacho Europa erwärmt sich schneller
als jeder andere Kontinent in Spanien
gibt es jetzt schon Regionen wo
zeitweise nichts mehr aus dem Wasser
ankommt und wissen Sie was vom Gardasee
noch übrig ist nicht viel nicht viele
Leute
ja der Gardasee quasi ein deutsches
Gewässer und die Ampel arbeitet der weiß
schon seit über anderthalb Jahren an
ihrem sogenannten Klimaschutz
Sofortprogramm so viele Fehler in einem
Wort
das Bundeskanzleramt befreit
Bundesverkehrsminister Volker Wissing
von der Pflicht für einen Klima
Sofortprogramm und das obwohl das
verkehrsressort die Vorgaben zum
CO2-Ausstoß für 2022 nicht erfüllt hat
ja kommt kein Stress oder kein Stress
der Volker hat aber auch durchaus Ideen
zur Klimarettung er hat diese Woche
ernsthaft vorgeschlagen wer sich ein
neues Auto kauft soll einen 49 Euro
Ticket umsonst dazu kriegen
lustiger wäre wenn man zu jedem
Zugticket umsonst ein neues Auto kriegt
fürs Klima und jetzt kommt direkt der
beste Witz der Sendung Volker Wissing
macht konkret mehr für den Klimaschutz
als die Forderungen der letzten
Generation und der klimakleber
das kannst du nicht mehr toppen das war
die heute schon meine Damen und Herren
nein nein nein ist Quatsch ist Quatsch
tatsächlich ist es vor allem für unseren
Völker ihre praktisch dass die Wut der
deutschen sich gerade ja auf eine
Handvoll Carglass in Warnwesten
fokussiert aber genau das will die
letzte Generation jetzt wohl ändern und
hat einen imageprofi engagiert nämlich
till Reiners von der PR-Agentur Sunshine
smile für was jetzt genau ja also gut
engagiert ist jetzt ein großes Wort also
ich berate die und stell anschließend
eine Rechnung und das Schöne ist die
können ja nicht weg
alte pr-regel die Leute immer da abholen
wo sie festkleben so Kinder erstmal ich
finde es super gut dass man gerade im
Moment bei euch um euch gar nicht herum
kommt also also weder mit dem Auto noch
thematisch ja ja und da hakt eben auch
ne like ability ja ihr seid mega
unbeliebt ja das würde ich doch nicht
gut an jeder Mensch will doch gemocht
werden und da setze ich an ja guck mal
die kann ich Auto fahren das nervt die
meisten fahren nämlich super gerne Auto
ne also statt ankleben vielleicht mal
weiß ich nicht selbst gebackenen Kuchen
verteilen den Berufsverkehr kann ja auch
vegan sein und dann eure Schilder Leute
oh ja handeln und zwar jetzt ist das
eine gute Laune Schild nein da sind
direkt zwei Wörter drin die der deutsche
hasst handeln und jetzt
sprechen davon von Wörtern so hier so
von Stars
so lass uns demnächst mal was machen
wenn es bei euch passt aber echt kein
Druck so
ja Weltrettung als Angebot ich kenne ja
auch nicht bei fremden Leuten an der Tür
Thermomix Kauf den du Arschloch ihr
müsst es den Menschen verkaufen und
niemand mag Verbote nicht immer dagegen
sein also auch Protest das kommt von Pro
für das Latein
in einer Waldorfschule
Null Humor war klar ja und dann die
Location warum Berlin okay als Ruine
coole Kulisse für ein Shooting ja aber
wenn ihr ausgerechnet hier den Verkehr
zum Erliegen bringt ist das für Berliner
ganz normaler Dienstag in keiner Stadt
Deutschland ist man so dran gewöhnt dass
nichts funktioniert mein Tipp München
wenn du in München 2 Kaugummis auf den
Gehweg schmeißt nenn dir das Chaos Tage
[Musik]
erweck ich bringe hier ein tote Augen ja
ich habe auch noch nicht ganz verstanden
für was die Sie bezahlen soll der für
Profitipps damit die Kids mal Follower
kriegen oder vielleicht sogar ein
Werbevertrag ne dass man den sinnlosen
Quatsch hier wenigstens monetarisiert
wisst ihr wie das geht zwei Wörter Tick
und Talk ich stehe jetzt mit euch einen
tiktok Video das geht durch die Decke so
pass auf Thema Klima das denken wir ab
hier mit dieser süßen Panda Maske so das
passt und wir brauchen natürlich Humor
das muss witzig sein hier
so
das ist fahren und Mucke ab bitte
[Musik]
winken und ein bisschen
oh mein Gott es regnet
[Musik]
chill Reiners vielen Dank nach Berlin
wir freuen uns gemeinsam denn
ein langes Wochenende steht bevor am
Montag ist Feiertag 1 Mai Tag der Arbeit
oder wir ganz vollständig heißt Tag der
Arbeit für die bei uns theoretisch jeder
mindestens Mindestlohn kriegt und das
unter menschenwürdigen Bedingungen was
aber in der Praxis leider so nicht immer
100%ig hinhaut ist halt so ja bisschen
sperriger Name für ein Feiertage
Ausbeutung findet wie das Leben immer
einen Weg oder wie Karl Marx sagen würde
ich habe es euch von Anfang an gesagt
Leute ja Ausbeutung
reden wir also kurz vor dem Tag der
Arbeit über die Logistikbranche fünf
Wochen lang haben 60 Lkw-Fahrer aus
Usbekistan und Georgien am Rastplatz
Gräfenhausen Südhessen an der A5
gestreikt wegen unmenschliche
Arbeitsbedingungen und weil sie
teilweise über Wochen manche sogar über
Monate gar kein Geld mehr gesehen haben
möglicherweise hätte da trotzdem kaum
einen Medium drüber berichtet aber dann
hat der polnische Spediteur ausgerechnet
am Karfreitag eine private
Sicherheitsfirma samt gepanzert im
Fahrzeug nach Hessen geschickt der
Schlägertrupp sollte die Fahrer wohl
einschüchtern und ihnen die Laster
abnehmen zum Glück Freunde kam zufällig
Cobra 11 vorbei und konnte Schlimmeres
verhindern man reibt sich wirklich die
Augen wild Western einer deutschen
Raststätte also eigentlich wild Ost
natürlich
der polnische Chef der Security Firma
versteht die Aufregung allerdings gar
nicht
das ist unsere Dienste schaust du diese
Auto ist auch gewesen in Deutschland äh
aber
warum nicht
warum nicht spannst du Auto schaust du
ja ich sage Ihnen da haben viele
Bundeswehr Generäle heulend vor dem
Fernseher gesessen
die haben gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
ja inzwischen will der polnische
Spediteur den ausstehenden Lohn bezahlen
der Streik war also so gesehen ein
Erfolg und das ist ganz wichtig er wirft
endlich ein schlaglich auf ein Business
in dem krasse Ausbeutung leider sehr
regelmäßig vorkommt immer noch klar auf
dem Papier haben wir in Deutschland
Mindestlohn Ruhezeiten Kontrollen aber
innerhalb der Europäischen Union sind
die Standard eben doch sehr
unterschiedlich auf unseren Autobahnen
sind Fahrer unterwegs die verdienen
höchstens die Hälfte von dem was in
Deutschland Angestellte verdient manche
kommen monatelang nicht nach Hause sei
du als ich Anfang letzten Jahres mit
dieser Arbeit begangen teilte der Chef
mir erstmal mit dass er künftig für die
Sonntage nicht mehr zahlen würde
im ersten Monat haben wir auch kein Geld
bekommen es hieß dass wir das Geld
nachträglich erhalten nachdem wir ein
Jahr gearbeitet haben
mein Gott und ich dachte immer das
größte Verbrechen in unseren Autobahn
wäre der sanifa Bong meine Damen und
Herren ja viele Fahrer werden von ihren
Chefs gezwungen Arbeitsschutzgesetze zu
ignorieren bei jeder dritten Kontrolle
werden Verstöße zum Beispiel gegen Lenk
oder Ruhezeiten festgestellt der
polnische Spediteur zum Beispiel hat
seinen Fahrern auch noch 100 € abgezogen
für kleine Kratzer an der Stoßstange
Sommer hoffentlich sind die wenigstens
ordentlich krankenversichert pro Jahr
und Fahrrad zahlt der polnische
Spediteur atmaz und luckmats angeblich
450 Euro in eine Krankenversicherung ein
allerdings soll diese Versicherung
nirgendwo gültig sein
ja nirgendwo gültig oder wie ist bei uns
heißt Kassenpatient ja so und dann
wundern wir uns aber das allein in
Deutschland an die 100.000 Fahrer fehlen
warte mal nach dem Gesetzen des Marktes
müssten die bei dem Fachkräftemangel
super bezahlt und super behandelt werden
das heißt ja der marktregel doch nicht
alles zum Guten mega Schock ja
stattdessen findet ein
Unterbietungswettbewerb statt jeden Tag
Subunternehmer aus Osteuropa holen sich
die Aufträge und dann gibt's Brett harte
Arbeit für lächerlich wenig Geld ich sag
mal davon träumen wirklich nur noch
Leute die gar keinen anderen Job mehr
finden
[Musik]
genau ja ja als Melania hörte dass die
Fahrer oft Monate nicht nach Hause
kommen
so Idee nur Idee wenn hier so viele
Fahrer fehlen bei uns dann könnten wir
doch die ganzen Georgier und Usbeken zu
deutschen also humanerin Konditionen
einstellen denkt man geht aber nicht
weil wir Ihren Führerschein nicht
anerkennen also der reicht doch immer
wieder hier durchzufahren der reicht
auch um monatelang auf unseren
Raststätten zu sagen wir mal Leben aber
nicht fürs angestellt werden bei einer
deutschen Firma gut vergessen war das
anderer Vorschlag Alternativvorschlag
endlich mehr Güter auf die Schiene
kriegt die Deutsche Bahn das hin ich bin
Lokführer im Güterzugverkehr und ich
fahre gleich den Zug der 5 Tage
Verspätung hat
deswegen muss ich nach Biblis aber sie
sehen ja wie kommen Sie jetzt von hier
weg ja weiß ich nicht
ja weiß ich nicht mit der Bahn
jedenfalls nicht ne
der lebt jetzt an dem Bahnhof meine
Damen und Herren gut ich ziehe den
Vorschlag zurück dann eben noch mehr
Laster Gefahren von ausgebeuteten die
von der A5 haben übrigens nach eigenen
Angaben auch waren Gefahren für große
Konzerne wie Ikea Mercedes oder VW ja ja
man fragt sich ist das diesen Firmen
also diesen großen Marken wenigstens
peinlich im Nachhinein sag mal mir wäre
das peinlich warum man werden jetzt in
dem Media der Reaktion sieht von der
großen Firma in die Lieferkette die
sagen oh keine Ahnung wie viel Filme
niemals schon gehört und wie viel fahre
fahren täglich für dich
aber das ist ja das geniale an
Subunternehmen ne man kann immer sagen
mit dem Ausbeute haben wir doch gar
keinen Vertrag und wir unser Direktor
Vertragspartner dieses unglaublich
günstige Angebot machen konnte doch
nicht hier neue Ikea spot
endlich die erste eigene Wohnung aber
wenig Geld für Möbel du und deine doofen
Hipster Freunde geht das Geld lieber für
Partys und saufen aus das geht dank
dieser netten Usbeken und Georgier sie
arbeiten auch mal Monate ohne Lohn und
schlafen für dich im Laster auf unserem
lkw-taschenbett Rückenschmerzen und
machen ihre Geschäft direkt ins chemikus
Ikea lieferst du vielleicht mal endlich
oder steigst du noch
nach wie vor
dem Teil der Logistikbranche und darüber
reden wir jetzt mit money Stockhaus er
ist Sprecher des Bundesverbands der in
Satire Sendung klischeehaft dargestellt
Fernfahrer hermani keiner will mehr
Trucker werden woran liegt moin moin ja
das ist echt rätselhaft also ich z.B
sind jetzt seit über 4 Stunden auf dem
Bock und glatt auf die Rücklichter von
dem rumänischen Schweine lassen das kann
man daran nicht mögen das war mal ein
Traumberuf König der Landstraße die
Mädels haben sich über unsere Aufkleber
Damen aufgepasst meiner ist 15 Meter
lang kannst du heute nicht mehr bringen
und sorry ich muss eben meine
Bohnensuppe umrühren ich mache das alles
während der Fahrt
Herr Stockhaus kleinen Augenblick noch
[Musik]
auf du Arschloch
ja du brauchst du gar nicht die Nase
rümpfen der welke in meinem Job bist du
trendy for seven unter Zeitdruck in
einer halben Stunde muss ich meine
vorgeschriebene Ruhezeit anfangen und
finde garantiert wieder keinen Parkplatz
in Deutschland fehlen zehntausende in
dem Wettrennen da kommt auf jede Minute
an da kannst du nicht fürs Essen
anhalten Essen auf Rädern für Bernd ganz
normale Alter
[Musik]
halleluja
ja so glamourös hätten sie sich das gar
nicht vorgestellt ne nein jeder vierte
Fahrer arbeitet über 60 Stunden die
Woche im Sitzen ist total ungesund viele
sind unfruchtbar wegen der Zeitung
meinte ja quasi auf einem 30 Tonnen
Eierkocher und dreht sich die Spermien
drehen
ja gut aber ich meine Hilfe ist ja
unterwegs das EU-Parlament diskutiert
jetzt die Missstände in eurer Branche
ach so ja prima dann sind wir hier alle
gerettet ich dachte immer was der
Missstand als Freundchen dass ihr
verwöhnten Batzen da draußen nicht zu
schätzen was wir hier leisten ein
Logistik Weltwunder ist ihr bestellt
irgendeine Scheiße im Internet und er
wartet dass er am nächsten Tag da ist ja
was denkt ihr denn wer das möglich macht
stimmt im Recht ist ja voll gedankenlos
ja da fällt mir ein ich habe heute
morgen einen neuen Sandwich-Toaster
bestellt und der ist immer noch nicht da
so ja nee klar dann nutze ich meine
Pause gleich und guck mal hinten nach
und das Schlimmste sind wir das
irgendwann alles nicht mehr aushalten
dann findet ihr andere
das deutsche Vater der kostet mir als
der tschechische der tschechische Kost
mehr als der ungarische oder rumänische
rumänische Kost mehr als der ukrainische
und ukrainische Kost mehr als der
philippinino und so geht das ganze halt
immer weiter nach Ostner
Hakuna Matata the circle of Ausbeutung
immer weiter nach Osten auf dem Globus
ist ja irgendwann wieder im Sauerland
ankommen ja
das ist wirklich schlimm aber was machen
wir denn da jetzt oh ja das ist
schwierig äh erste Idee nur mal so
rumgesprochen mehr Geld mehr Parkplätze
Raststätten Kaffee für unter 5 € und
Sanitäranlagen wo man auch ohne
Gummistiefel rein kann nicht mal
Wildpinkeln geht mehr weil überall diese
wütenden
mein Gott ey schick mir noch Richtung
Autobahn stellen
willst oder hast du nur Dreckschweine
oder ja klar reden noch ein bisschen
länger Pimmel aus
ich habe Todesangst vor dir
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt Schluss machen da ich
gleich mit Sicherheit wieder keinen
Parkplatz finde und illegal auf dem
Standstreifen übernachte dann mache ich
mich jetzt schon mal fertig für die
Nacht hier warte mal eben Abendbrot hier
Halleluja Zähneputzen
muss reichen
und jetzt duschen
und jetzt schön Pipi
ah ich verspreche ich bestelle nie
wieder was Holger Stockhaus meine Damen
und Herren
also dann los
liebe Fans der feinsten Unterhaltung
Klick hier hin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
das war's super take
aus heute